let's go to sarah in san antonio texas
sarah how are we doing
i'm doing good how about you outstanding
that's good okay so i'll give you kind
of a quick rundown um
i'm a currently a grad student paying
out of pocket
i have around 7 500 in debt
for my undergraduate years i'm applying
for
7500 okay yeah
um i'm applying for state trooper and
i won't know if i'm accepted until
november or december
um and i want to build a tiny house on
wheels no
my budget would be around twenty
thousand
to twenty five um so my question is is
because i'm on a short time crunch
should i pull out a loan
no no no no no sarah sarah says
again no okay
how old are you sarah uh 21 21 years old
why do you want to get a tiny house well
i know why she wants to get a ton house
because you know that's what that's what
millennials are doing and
i'm not mad at sarah let's let her
answer sarah why do you want to get a a
tiny house
um i really like to travel and
i think with state trooper i would just
be moving around a lot
and i don't want to get into serious
debt buying a house that i may not want
to live in
yeah one thing i can guarantee you're
not going to want to live in for a long
time is a tiny house
i know that looks so cool on youtube i
promise it looks so cool i watch it all
the time
i even watch the netflix documentaries i
know it feels cool
yeah so sarah let's let's let's let's
walk let's walk through this process
what's your total amount of debt right
now outside of your loans how much do
you totally owe in debt right now
um that's it 7 500
no credit cards no car notes no nothing
nope
okay cool are you generating any income
right now
um i work with my family but
no i guess not no all right and so
you're 21 years old and right now
uh you are about to go into the school
this is what i really want you to do
number one
we need to go ahead and get you into a
solid um
income you're already going down that
path to start that journey okay
now uh i agree with jade uh that
with dr john that long term you're not
going to want to do this but i will also
admit
that uh in this generation of young
people a lot of
young people in our generation because
i'm in this this bracket as well
we really want to try this get on the
road travel the world for two three
years and
and do this fun stuff and and i have no
problem with that but here's where i do
have a problem with it
you don't really have a foundation to
stand on you know you don't have a
stable income
you don't have a fully funded emergency
fund and there's really no solid game
plan
so before i'm not going to knock your
dream because i disagree with knocking
dreams
what i want to do is i want to help you
set yourself up to where your dream
doesn't become a nightmare
and if you go by a house on wheels
without having the right foundation your
dream now becomes nightmare
so going ahead get into your career
field going ahead
set aside a fully funded emergency fund
going ahead
and then from there start investing and
start saving up money to do what you
want to do
and if that's what you want to do that's
fine we don't have a problem with you
doing what you want to do
we just want you to do it the right way
you understand what we're saying sarah
yeah so would you just recommend i just
i'm not really a fan of of staying in an
apartment and just putting in
hundreds of dollars on a house or an
apartment that's not mine you know it
won't be mine
yeah but i mean but but let me let me
ask you this question why not
because right now what you're doing is
is you're setting aside
money to eventually do what you want to
do
right now you're not making a hundred
thousand dollars right now you don't
have 25 000
to put on a house on wheels you don't
have that
so if you want to stay at home for maybe
a year
build up some income that's fine but i
do believe at 21 years old
if you have the opportunity to step out
on your own and really start developing
some some grown adult skills and some
grown adult experiences
i would definitely do that be maturing
and becoming this grown person at a
young age is more important
to me than actually going out there and
dropping a lot of money
on a vehicle that's on wheels and sarah
here's the reality if you get into the
state trooper's office
i think they're going to make you was it
moved to austin for a year and then
they're going to stick you in el paso
somewhere for another year or
six months or 18 months and
buying a 25 000 potentially depreciating
asset i know
trailers do i don't know how even a loan
would work against a
house on wheels my guess is it would end
up being similar to a trailer loan
and which means you'd be taking out a
loan against a depreciating asset like a
fancy car
and you're gonna look up three years
later and your tiny house is going to be
worth
less and you're going to be in the same
situation just with this burden
with this asset that you've paid money
into that's not worth as much as you're
going to get rid of it if you do the
math over 36 months when you finally
land in the city where you're going to
end up doing your job as a state trooper
you're going to end up finding that you
are in about the same position if not
better
from renting in a cheap apartment in
each one of these towns you're going to
bounce around too for the next few years
yeah yeah and i'm telling you um at the
beginning of this call
i was talking noise about tiny homes
here's the truth i would love a few tiny
homes on my house right now
my wife and i always laugh about i want
my own tiny house and she wants her own
tiny house and then we'll just build
like a
place where we eat dinner together in
the middle i love them i think they're
cool
and i know it feels like you'd be
getting ahead of the game but starting
off
7 500 in debt plus your continuing
school plus now you got a 25 000
mortgage against a trailer it's just
setting yourself up to be way in the
hole before you even get going
and that's if you're for sure gonna get
this job being a state trooper is a hard
job to get into
you just got a lot of unknowns down the
road just slow down i know you don't
feel like getting an apartment
do it anyway get out on your own like
anthony said start building some wisdom
start building some skills
and that the mortgage and the home will
come just be patient with yourself